the path the warpath path of war moving
toward a battle fight towards the actual
war against our nation's enemies or the
war against my own weaknesses preparing
and and sharpening my sword and honing
my skills and maintaining the
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things where does it lead it can be
in fact I am waiting in a because the
warpath is a war against weakness and so
it needs to sway its
war against ignorance and so it needs to
polish
delivers others need
the warpath needs to control and leads
to ownership of your life
and that is the warpath
fired in adversity the path of blood and
of sweat and of suffering
is
a path of discipline which is why
it means the food and beyond that in the
end
it beats